that's the final episode john why don't
you take the lead on this one guys we
are gonna check out new rockstars easter
eggs and break down for the moon night
episode six season finale once you go
ahead if you haven't done so already
subscribe to new rockstars also click
the like button on this video helps out
a bunch subscribe over here as well hit
that notification bell to get notified
whenever our next marvel series starts
up let's see what awesome easter eggs
eric and the gang have to point out
today
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of moon
night episode 6 the season finale in
which jake lockley finally reveals
himself to say baya con dios from
layla's new fit to i kid you not another
verified kang easter egg what
are the details that you missed in this
episode now before the episode even
begins the previously on segment opens
with arthur harrow firing his shots at
mark back in episode four gunshots that
jake lockley will volley back at him in
the final shot of this finale
1958 song the end with lyrics describing
how things like rainbows and stories
have finite ends to look forward to but
the speaker's love has no end in the way
that this episode that marvel has
suggested would be a series finale has
since been changed to just a season
finale since there is obviously
confirmed yes step out right now because
i feel like that is super telling and
that's pretty awesome oscar isaac must
be pleased so we'll get some more with
jake lock me yeah this is obviously a
setup for season two that'd be weird if
it wasn't the season two yeah but you
know i mean i don't know it seems like
they go out of their way to establish
certain things and make us wonder if
they will just be limited series so it's
nice to at least have the confirmation
especially because the credits didn't
end with moon knight would return you
know absolutely and this music drifts
away as we fade in on mark
at the end
[Music]
yeah earl sings the words at the end of
a river the water stops its flow right
as we see mark bobby dead in that water
and the audio mix works in sounds of
crashing waves along the bank of a river
despite mark floating in just this mere
puddle just a cool way of linking him to
steven's drowning in the sandy ocean
hero says sorry i'd have to be this way
mark specter
stephen and grant
whoever else might be in there rabbi
lachlan
is indeed a third alter still inside
that body the one who will avenge these
gunshots and as sarah places a scarab on
his chest mark's star david necklace is
visible another reminder of how egyptian
mythology and the mysticism of judaism
in the covering of mirrors during the
shiva mourning periods are equally
important to mark especially in his
relationship to his own reflection
harrow turns he actually explores some
judaism once in a while
and again on his steps the audio mixes
in sounds of that crunching glass which
this episode finally drops the smoke
screen on as mark and steven see hero's
true nature harrow proudly holds up
neil another indiana jones reference and
raiders of the lost ark when bellock
hold up the golden idol and all the men
knelt which indy used as a chance to
escape arrow staff now transforms into
an upgraded weapon the left side croc
head bending over to form one large croc
head leaving that back half as a blade
this whole thing transitioning from a
balanced swinging pendulum of justice to
something closer to an executioner yeah
exactly
an early indicator of her final form
this episode the scarlet scarab scarlet
scarab i want to go out greg was the one
before we even started shooting you know
the review portion i'm pretty sure that
that's a reference to the scarlet scarab
coy and i were a little more skeptical
of that take we were wrong clearly it is
a direct reference to the scarlet scarab
and clearly they are continuing that
sort of reworking of the original
scarlet scarab identity into laylah's
identities nikoi still vouches that it's
still a stretch i mean it would be cool
to see them actually introduce an
original character in one of these shows
i just think it's another classic case
of a white man of certain his dominance
that's what i say koi if you're watching
i'm very uncomfortable right now hero
uses a staff to suck out soldiers souls
just interesting how these purple souls
float upward signaling how the
underworld isn't beneath our feet but
similar to the mcu depictions of
valhalla when odin floated off to it
it's a spiritual plane with no
directional vector to get there tarant
uses corpses to speak to layla it's mark
who's telling you to stop he's dead and
i'm speaking to you through dead people
right now so what yeah the actor who
plays that soldier ahmed said does such
a good job matching antonio celib's hand
gesture is a demeanor as tower it and
you can be my at the top
of the chamber
is line up against them you won't
believe what the gods are hidden from
mankind
you're judges not warriors
this doesn't need to happen yeah right
at the end of the avatar's bodies
straighten up and their eyes roll back
showing that harrow is fighting the gods
in their human vessels yet since amit is
a beastly devourer she is more hostile
in combat that fight goes unseen but at
the end of it isis avatar is left
splayed on those steps while it gets
sealed hawthorne's avatar is frozen on
the floor her arm's still reaching out
her finger's not exactly limp on her
hand there in a similar pose as the one
steven was left in i think that would be
cool returning to moon knight i mean i
know a lot of these gods literally just
got murked but it would be nice to see
more of those forms and more of the
avatars and just venture further out
because i feel like this phase of the
mcu especially has had to do a lot with
the powers that be and the people who
are guiding the currents of time and
space for whatever you know school of
thought that you uh subscribe to or
whatever you know we get on it we get
conscious obviously and then the rest
were sort of just in regular human form
you know i know they had a lot to manage
within the finale but part of me was
like dang you know i feel like some of
the other gods might have been a little
bit more directly involved in actual
godly form i just love the way they've
incorporated the mythology into the
series overall so i'd love to see more
of that in season two so hero finally
releases ahmet voiced by actress saba
mubarak and i just love ahmed's
character design with her crocodile
tails snaking that actually is hot as
hell damn
linen wrappings around her head and
dangling from her snout cover and mocap
immediately he also mummified though she
is not as weathered as he is whereas
tawarat's ears would always wiggle here
when ahmet looks right at the camera the
eye on the left twitches just a little
bit like a little crocodile wink ahmet
tells hero that his skills lack balance
which is something that she approves of
because that imbalance means that lying
ahead of them is some service to her and
she says i once relied on a servant
whose scales balanced perfectly
in exchange
i was bound to stone for 2 000 years
yeah the final avatar she's referring to
was alexander the freaking great whom
harrow hinted betrayed her to the gods
now ahmet is suggesting alexander's
scales were balanced perfectly so it's
confirmed in the history of the mcu
alexander the great was a successful
conqueror thanks to amit yes he was
still great in his own heart
that's pretty cool
asks her to be his avatar but she's like
nope you need a plan
little bug yes the way kanchu called
steven nicknames like worm he does the
same for layla which also foreshadows
the way layla uses an insect for her
moniker as a star
the forger explained how layla's father
called her his little scarab mark takes
in the field of reeds it's so
quiet yes the same words dr otto
octavius says when peter fixes them and
spiderman had no way home oh
those voices
inside my head i'd almost forgot because
it is
these characters and in a world that was
once noisy has now gone silent oh
crap similar to the greek myth of
orpheus crossover than we thought love
eurydice because this series core
dramatic relationship is the brotherhood
and the love between mark and steven
it's a story of self-love and
self-acceptance you
are the only real superpower i ever had
and so we get this sweet anna and elsa
moment where they're one shared heart
not they're too hard separately trying
to balance the scale just one heart
shared together un-frozen
osiris of course being the egyptian god
of the underworld and of resurrection
two things one i thought that was a
really really beautiful resolution and
even though we did gripe about some of
the finale feeling a little slight on
the emotional stakes or a little rushed
in certain circumstances i thought that
reunion of mark and steven and their
bonding together was absolutely gorgeous
also no anubis whatsoever like in the
you know the comic that this is largely
derived from we have anubis who's you
know sort of guiding the raft through
the sort of overvoid duat area and uh
here it's all osiris but you know being
repped by tolerance there's only so much
i think you can throw into six episodes
of a marvel show and clearly this
episode jam-packed a lot in and of
itself as well so i don't think we had
time for anubis you had to keep it a
little bit condensed and you'd probably
confuse people with the jackals i guess
so after passing through this gate mark
breathes once more in the tomb mark
i feel the pain
inside of you
do you want death
or do you want life and then this
montage we flash back to that cave
moment in chicago when last episode
stephen
bones and that memory suggesting konchu
did project himself in mark's memory to
help him feel less alone when he looks
back on that traumatic event and in this
way suggests he was there to decide his
whole life his breakdown outside his
mom's shiva obviously his possession but
also his marriage with layla and now the
bullets hit the ground this close-up
evoking neo's resurrection in the matrix
yeah bullets in the floor this time when
the wrappings in case's body it happens
more slowly it's that gentle swaddling
like a loving re-embraced by konchu and
then his breastplate layer comes in
significantly after gushing outward in a
heart shape mark it's going to negotiate
with konchu and kanji turns it from day
to night mark leaping into the light of
the full moon his keep eclipsing it in a
crescent shape let's end tower it i
would be delighted to accept you as my
avatar
oh your father is going to be over the
moon when he is my father yes i met him
when i took him to the field of reads
yes tarah confirms that she did take
layla's dead father into the field of
reads i like how she says over the moon
just some nice work play for layla in
her family history being over and beyond
the influence of the moon deity that's
ruined their lives just want to take a
quick beat to give some major props to
make kalimawi as much as oscar isaac is
the centerpiece and steals so much of
the show she does a terrific job and i
thought that back and forth between
layla and towerette in her one body was
really nicely done so i'm glad that you
know she was one of the main takeaways
people had from this episode especially
because you actually end this one they
have like a power couple dynamic which
is something you don't get enough of in
the mcu glad it wasn't just like she
inhabits moon knight you know we got
female moon yeah and now you got your
own separate character as well and also
it is funny that this character is
jewish but there's and there's so many
jesus allegories which got a certain
ryan somebody some twitter trouble a
couple weeks ago that's the reason i'm
mentioning that
so pray for ryan taylor unleashes
ahmed's judgment over cairo and his
disciple bobby preaches what is
essentially the creed of twitter judge
everyone
all egyptians are the same
and they all directed moonlight
especially see giant omit and then later
also see giant khanshu because episode 2
did establish that regular poke cannot
see konchu kick the trash bin or see the
jackal smash into stuff and that these
supernatural forms only present
themselves to those they wish to see
them and also we don't really see any
reaction shots of the egyptians looking
up and going holy [ __ ] a giant crocodile
and a giant bird skeleton layla
emergency new suit from tower ranch as
the scarlet scarab confirmed my marvel
you can see the red oh damn there you go
even more
now in the marvel comics the scarlet
scarab is abdulfa egyptian villain to a
group called the invaders which include
cap bucky human torch neymar and union
jack this series has given us this with
layla's name being laila abdullah el
fawoli and that red scarab her bandages
oh
dang it
have shown a scarab with her holding
that scarlet colored flare mark
confronts hero and i love how the frame
rotates on the incline of the pyramid
with the full moon behind them amazing
because harrow has a high ground and
only has to run downward whereas mark
has the low ground and must run up yet
sprints at the same speed as harrow and
hits him with a power uppercut the moon
framing this all makes it clear that
this round goes to mark giant konshu
fights giant ahmet right as mark and
steven fight harrow in an aerial battle
now despite the trope of giant cgi
battles and the climaxes of many mcu
titles i actually don't mind it here
because as is often the case in
mythology the battle between mortals is
a proxy for a higher tier feud between
the gods there's one thing too i think
this show did really nicely as like
mirroring and incorporating the themes
of the mythology not that i'm an expert
on egyptian mythology or anything like
that but really making it feel way more
than just like window dressing or a way
to make something look fresh but be the
same like they really lived in that
world in a very nice way even with the
previous shot of them running up and
down at each other like just the themes
of above and below are really nicely
handled here i thought yeah and also say
that when we filmed these and we got
these lights and we're usually further
back that actually being closer and
having the screen less obscured i'm like
oh the visual effects look so much
better
from where we're sitting now versus a
couple seats back here that way it's
basically how good things look when you
can actually see them you know layla
saves mark deflecting harrow's blast
with her golden wings and crossing their
arms and then later saving a van full of
people
yes given how outspoken mama diob was
about wonder woman 1984's depictions of
egypt it's hard not to see all of this
as an intentional dig at that movie and
diana's getting winged armor and by the
way the
wow
and the handoffs between stephen and
mark stevens baton getting deflated one
of mark's altars is a graffiti artist
stephen is kicked across the alley marks
grappling hook shoots out of that dust
but it ends with harrow pinning down
mark then we black out
[Music]
jake remains in the moonlight so jake
lockley obviously took over here as he
did in episode three with the thugs on
the roof and in the transition at the
end of episode two when mark suddenly
found himself in the egyptian hotel and
probably the violent blackouts when all
those guys ended up dead in the alpine
village here when mark wakes up he's
nearly plunging that axe blade in a
hero's head and in addition to harrow's
men now dead around them there's also a
bunch of flames that were not there
before cars wrecked and burnt in that
shot behind them whereas before it was
undamaged now the neon sign is mostly
out and a fluorescent bulb dangles so we
still do not know what j suit looks like
or how powerful he is but presumably
this suit is capable of unleashing some
explosive targeted shock waves
possessing some kind of power beyond the
healing powers in the weaponry of mark's
ceremonial attire actually that third
look might be visible for a few frames
in the credits right before we flash the
hood
another form with frayed mummy wrappings
over the face but with the eyes left
exposed that could be what jake lockley
looks like when he takes charge
obviously it's gonna be awesome to see
whatever they or at least to anticipate
and finally see whatever they reveal to
be jake lockley's suit but also just the
one thing i am really excited about and
maybe more so than a lot of the other
mcu shows is to go back and re-watch and
see all the different sort of pieces
that add up because i think early on in
the reviews and stuff we were expressing
this wish that you know after a certain
point we hoped they would save jake
lockley for the very end and use that as
some kind of big reveal and i like the
way they did that here and there are so
many wonderful little clues and details
to catch up on and i wonder if any of
those might hint at what the look is or
or anything moving forward you know i'd
like jake lockley just to
be in his
hat
it's just a hat made of mummy wrapping
because that's the jake lockley look
that's what i thought was cool was he
was just an assassin he might not have
an actual moon knight or mr knight kind
of she was like you know what actually
you're you're you're good like when he
literally when he assassinates arthur
harrow at the end he's not dressed in
some avatar suit he's just dressed like
a normal dude on recover so yeah i think
it'd be kind of cool they just kept him
that way layla and marcus is failed to
immortalize ahmet but mark cannot bring
himself to execute harrow so kanchu
agrees to release them we think but
stephen wakes up in hero's office where
they now see the blood pulling from his
sandals the implication might be that
harrow's feet in the series were always
bleeding but mark steven all of us did
not see it until now kind of like in the
thing oh fascinating sees what he wants
to see and that color red's true
significance is not clear until it all
comes into focus but this office i
believe is not real not like the rest of
the hospital that we saw in episode five
the hospital was their perspective of
the duat underworld ship rather this
room is their organizing principle
representing their subconscious
self-doubt so last episode they would
suddenly teleport back to this room when
one of them suffered a mental break so
this ned flanders is not hero it's the
embodiment of doubt that hero's
antagonism represents for them and now
that they see harrow as the bleeding
mortal he truly is they are no longer
trapped under their doubts control they
control it so stephen says goodbye with
hey this guy is
showing both his closure with their mum
but also their departure from amit's
spirit inside harrow and the final scene
takes mark instead so we're so wrong
opening shot of the series waking up in
their london flat once again listening
to angle bear humber deaks a man without
love the tank now has two goldfish
reflecting mark and stephen coexisting
the brothers learning to share but they
fall on their face once again restrained
by the ankle this restraint and the fish
when you think about it represented one
altar keeping another altar trapped in a
tank and now jake lockhart has really
done that to both of them what mark had
done wait a minute the credit sequence
shows there's now a full moon an
evolution throughout the series now
symbolizing mark's wholeness with
stephen but the post-credits scene shows
harrow in another psychiatric hospital
actually first to see a shot of a rubber
ducky dressed as a doctor maybe a nod to
him being a quack doctor in mark's mind
the way steven has always been
surrounded by sand on the series now
harrow sees sand in his coffee cup but
spills it showing the kind of clumsiness
steven would show whenever he fell on
his face getting out of his bed but
harrow still has that tattoo meaning
this is the same real life guy from the
before this isn't in anyone's head the
nurse is waved away
i beg your pardon
yeah it is off screen but jake did
something to woo or flatter that nurse
like she doesn't know where to put her
hands either she is awkward or smitten
just proving this guy to be a smooth
womanizer who asked out dylan back in
the museum jacob should we question his
voice
and why is that speaking spanish anymore
unlikely a nod to oscar isaac's ancestry
perhaps even hinted at by the masayado
sol last episode which now plays once
more from the limo but they will pass
this poster with a qr code this is the
same qr code that's been hidden in
several episodes this season but now
when you scan this with your phone the
page that it takes you to has been
updated to a 2019 moon night comic in
which moon knight faces kang the
conqueror wow
night after week that should be a big
ass hint okay obviously did not appear
in the series they really didn't need
him in the story but still this is a
moon knight producers hinting that the
connected yeah all of this and who knows
moon knight or the scarlet scarab konshu
tower oh that's so clever man in a
future mcu appearance like loki season
two maybe man wants spontaneous oh
that's so clever i'm gonna just call
loki season two right now because it's
the obvious thing to call but that is
really awesome and i feel like one of
the main sort of things people have
echoed throughout this phase is i
thought this so many more things were
going to connect to loki and kang and i
thought kang was going to be so much
more important to like the immediacy of
this phase and so it's cool to see that
they are still setting up those threads
and for a character like this to be you
know getting those easter eggs i cannot
wait to see them collide in some way
shape or form especially because too i
mean kang has uh the the pharaoh persona
you know that he lived in at one point
so maybe even we could see that in a
following season in some kind of
flashback or whatever it's nice to see
kang back in the fold you know i think
it would have been too much if they try
putting kang in one of these actual
scenes inside of moon knight like to
keep it focused and just keep it focused
on the story itself because those
barcodes always reflective of each
episode but to do your future mcu bigger
universe setup that way and to allude to
that through a true easter egg one that
an audience member has to go out of his
or her own way to go find is a great way
to to make it even more of a mysterious
setup but a direct indication that moon
knight in some way might collide with
the king outside this hospital it's
called psykowitz psychiatric hospital a
nod to bill cycloids a comic artist who
contributed so much of how moon knight
looks rather than the taxi jake drives
in the comics
spectre plates just like the ride mr
knight takes in the comics now this
might be nothing but one of the men
standing outside has the same long white
hair oh it's crawling i don't know if
this is just an actor cameo or all of
reality crumbling now inside people know
conscious sitting in there wearing the
fancy suit as he does in that same run
of the comics and he says that he was
never interested in taking leilah's
avatar since his number one is the
hidden altar mark and steven never saw
the one in the red sarcophagus jay
glockly
[Music]
you are my way of life a song about
eternal devotion like the devotion
between jake and konchu a devotion
hopefully we will see more of if we ever
get a second season of this show i want
to thank you all for joining us in these
breakdowns of moon night this season you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
at ea boss follow new rockstars
subscribe to rockstars more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye i appreciate that episode a lot more
now you absolutely i absolutely do too i
feel like maybe it was a little harsh on
it just sitting and thinking on it and
especially after this i'm really excited
to watch it again well anyway guys what
are your thoughts on the finale are you
satisfied at the end of this are you
excited for moon night season 2 leave it
all down below remember to subscribe to
us subscribe to new rock stars let's do
a
flev doran the marvel video and you know
we gotta shout you out on a marvel video
but this was a finale that ended in such
a positive way with such a lovely
embrace of the characters and that's how
i feel when you comment or you engage
with us in any way i just feel a loving
supportive embrace and i would be happy
to share a body with you man i feel like
it would be a good roomy scenario just
in either your body or mine whichever
one as long as our spirits get to
intermingle and congeal and nerd out
together i think that would be a lovely
way to spend eternity and just know i
would never ever sacrifice you to the
sands of death if we were in some kind
of high-stakes adventure scenario all
right i would sacrifice myself for you
phleb that's how much i love you that's
how much i don't value my own body hope
you're doing well hope you enjoyed the
finale and we'll catch you soon buddy
[Music]